good morning everyone today is a very
special day for professional ethics and
let me introduce you to mr. James
Alexander but before I would like to say
some words
oddly enough ethics is a practical
choice for the students of today facing
the job market of tomorrow philosophy
helps us to cultivate critical thinking
communication creative problem-solving
and collaboration while also nurturing
our intellectual curiosity and mental
agility that will serve us well when the
careers of the future turn out to be the
ones we could not predict what is the
best place for studying ethics the
thrill of discovering what ideas can do
and of thinking hard and what about what
they mean they mean moral philosophy is
not just a means to other ends it is the
record of many stories we have told
about ourselves and our world and of the
many ways we have found to use language
artfully and beautifully it both
reflects us and shapes us standing up
for what we actually learn might turn
out to work better than we imagined even
those who claim to see no use for ethics
often tacitly acknowledge its importance
especially at times of high emotion of
our deep significance how often do
people turn to a black moral philosophy
because they recognize at some level
that it offers them something they
cannot find anywhere else
well today we are going to find many
answers thanks to our guests
mr. James Alexander former Yale alumni
who after majoring in economics got an
MBA from Harvard Business School then he
started his journey in corporate America
he came back to his alma mater to study
at the Divinity School and he's coming
back today to share his experiences in
the real world when something sometimes
the lack of solid solid moral compass
and a toxic corporate culture can cause
terrible damage to many please help me
wait mr. Alexander to our class today I
[Applause]
don't know about the answers part
experience and definite point of view I
can provide answers I keep thinking
about what the answers are but I always
seem to be baffled what I'm gonna try to
do hopefully not take too long is to
describe two completely different
corporate cultures pervasive corporate
cultures you might say that I
experienced at the start of my career in
the mid 70s and really became
increasingly fed up with by about 2000
to be able to describe those the
dynamics which led from one to the other
and to render plausible the thought that
the corporate culture which ended up
developing
which I think gave us Enron and gave us
the financial crisis is not the only
alternative and is situated in a
specific historical situation which
could be shifted the old the the
corporate culture that I started in was
very much one that the almost Robin I'm
recognizable today very group oriented
very accepting of government regulation
very concerned with ethical boundaries
and you know less positively was very
oriented to to rip the corporate
traditions as they existed in each
company regardless of whether anyone
come up with a good reason for why the
traditions were there looking at the end
and I'll try to fill in what happened in
the middle not only were these points of
view eroded they really were reversed
that government regulation became viewed
is completely harmful that it's
self-evident and the new view
responsibilities to the self always
trump those to the group the what might
be viewed in the new world as the old
ethical rigidities were displaced at
least in financed by much more will call
the flexible risk return calculus and
more beneficially that business
traditions or suspect which obviously
I'm receptive to the others maybe I
flagged too clearly that I'm not to be
able to show what happened I have to be
able to sort of go through the major
corporate players at each corporation
you know this generically top
management's the private sector
gatekeepers where you have basically the
reputational intermediaries like the
boards of directors
outside corporate counsel auditors and
then the public sector gatekeepers all
of which are in theory supposed to keep
corporations headed down a path that is
legally stable productive and honest but
looking let's look at the way business
was when I started which I'm not trying
to prove or trade this is a golden era
far from it I'm trying to be balanced
and looking at it it was very slow
growth five to six percent if you're
looking at earnings per share which is a
standard metric five to six percent sort
of growth which today of course would
get you destroyed taken over was
actually accepted back that the that
again looking at the metrics for how you
look at how expensive stocks are trading
p/e multiples price earnings multiples
and percent of breakup value they're
very low very low multiples because
basically there was no takeover market
and you had low growth low growth of
companies in response dividend yields
which is annual dividend divided by the
stock price dividend eul's were hired to
be able to to make up for this lack of
growth top manager compensation was very
modest and mostly salary based and it
wasn't salary based it was sort of
fairly stingy bonuses given out by
fairly traditional boards the negative
part of this is a little market
discipline for underperforming
management's there were almost no one
friendly takeovers no one really had to
worry about much of anything so if you
look at the top management's what types
of people occupied this they weren't
profit maximizers they were satisficers
they were trying to balance competing
interests workers customers shareholders
local community they're very loyal to
their traditional private sector
gatekeepers their bankers accountants
and lawyers very protective of company
reputation and very concerned about its
long-term health oh ok so we have the
top management so the next group you
know sort of proceeding outward from the
center of power the boards of directors
who had a very clubbing mentality it was
a very very male-dominated hierarchy
surprising emphasis on etiquette in
commenting over any heart heart thinking
about deep issues loyal and deferential
to the CEOs to the extent they different
with CEOs is because they wanted to
maintain traditions and status quo and
they were concerned about change again
proceeding outward in terms of people
that were part of but less and less
powerful within this corporate Nexus you
had the top corporate lawyers but the
same themes were very you'll see over
and over in this old form of
organization little inner firm
competition they were politically
dominant over the in-house councils very
little client turnover and lo lawyer
compensation where lawyers bankers and
accountants were all compensated with a
fairly modest way the cultural
characteristics were equally important
they were very respectful the SEC they
were concerned about balancing
securities bouncing the concern for
securities laws and full adherence to
their letter and spirit with legitimate
client interests protective of their
firm and client reputation and looking
to ensure stability you see the same
themes coming out for why you would have
a very stable but low growth situation
auditors would be the first ones to
change also had similar characteristics
a little inner firm competition little
consulting work to threaten audit
independence the elder generation of big
8 partners they're worried firms that
and the 70s were still generally ethical
and by when I use ethics in the sense of
a corporate counsel and auditors I'm
emphasizing that the disclosures by the
company are fair and and demonstrate a
real concern for economic substance and
are not intended to deceive or to
confuse however even in the 70s you
could start you can see that they were
starting to be erosion of these Nicole
vanishing attitudes
we're already auditors were starting to
sort of say well you know what would you
like when you when you were talking
about potential ways of treating
ambiguous transactions so they were
already signs of change going on with
some well-known frauds major commercial
banks again highly regulated little
competition from outside of the industry
but little expansion opportunity within
the industry
there was no brokerage or corporate
underwriting it was a buy-and-hold type
of approach to business there was no
securities pure ization very little
trading low growth and a low-risk
business that's what people were aiming
for and happy with the with the major
banks who especially are going to be one
of the major changing forces in this in
this whole transition the top to bottom
Ephesus was preserving a long term
customer relationships maintaining the
firm's reputation engaging an ethical
pregnant business practice and not
losing the depositors money no one
really cared about innovation and it was
a boring stable hidebound approach to
business which people were thoroughly
happy with rightly or wrongly okay well
finish I think we go
one more before this last one for the
SEC brokerage industry same thing
because of what happened in the
Roosevelt administration both banking
and brokerage were highly regulated
there was no competition coming from
outside the industry commissions were
cartelized at a high level and there was
a generally stable industry hierarchy
just like the commercial banks very
little amount of equity was needed
because there's very little high-risk
trading Salomon was going to come in and
disrupt this but at the time there was
little capital or risk-taking devoted to
sales and trading and little risk-taking
with respect to the reputation of of
your firm and since it's basically the
same thing as the banks that will be
labor there was a gentlemen's game and
unfortunately it was very male-dominated
and most major firms same attitudes as
the bankers in terms of emphasis on long
term client relationships and
maintaining firm reputation the public
sector gatekeepers were both or both of
them or SEC and Fed were proud of their
history of the oversight of their
businesses under their purview they were
certain of their value to the regulated
industry in case the SEC to an honest
and efficient securities markets and
they had strong relationships with with
the brokers in the case the SEC and the
banks in the case of the Fed and they
trusted private sector gatekeepers to do
their part and that's important for both
of them because they've raised over
generations of having their regulated
industry be very receptive to the
regulation so what were the core the
common themes slow-growth stable
competitive hierarchies which did tend
toward oligopolies at times company
strategies focus on minimizing risk not
maximizing upside and highly regulated
in the case of finance but one might say
was sticking the mud cultural
values you know from the point of view
looking at their values view of what
would end up coming up later you know
they really did have a lethargic
acceptance of government regulation they
did have a complete conviction that
responsibilities the group limited the
acceptable range of individual goals and
that long-term reputations were much
more important than short-term advantage
and they trusted up the other other
players to feel the same way so the
first industry to really be they had
this way of thinking destroyed was the
brokerage industry with the deregulation
of stock commissions in 1975 by the sec
the old industry oligopoly which was
stable somewhat inefficient stodgy
butBut ethical was really almost
destroyed within a few years by the
deregulation of stock on training
commissions then it was these these
changes were further reinforced by a
series of changes which basically
allowed the banks to start to come into
the the brokerage firms traditional ways
of traditional lines of business on the
other hand the same time that the SEC it
was destroying the old ways of doing
business reinforced by the Fed the there
were new opportunities arising and the
most important was the development was
called the high-yield bond market which
really started in the late 70s and
became a roaring success in the 80s
where firms traditionally too high-risk
to get public bond sales and had to be
financially to the banks which then
restricted their activities started
through this successive Drexel to be
to get almost unlimited amounts of funds
to do what they wanted to do also in the
late 70s Salomon Brothers sold its first
private mortgage-backed security issue
and in sterli 80 started developing
interest rate swaps all of these are
starting to take the old stable
investment banking hierarchy and
destroyed it finally the next thing
they'll probably the most important
thing on that slide 1985 Drexel raised
the first higher bond financing of a
hostile takeover and with this
everything and I'll try to show how this
had ramify effects on the entire culture
and it's basically there were a series
so you might say of finance IEDs in the
road of each major company so looking at
the brokerage industry what happened
well the old corporate finance people
who are the old club ty types starting
to lose out to sales and trading brains
mergers and acquisitions which was
filled with the more rapacious of the
investment bankers went out over the old
Coca phoniness people who couldn't
change research which is supposed to be
able to inter mediate between the
innocent banking firms and the buyers of
these securities lost because with the
new compressed Commission structure
research couldn't pay for itself anymore
so ok so the old ways of business lose
out and emanate and M&A and sales and
trading win but what sort of people
populated citizen trading in M&A well
they're much smarter and more aggressive
less obsessed with doing the right thing
I'm concerned with the long term if like
if they got what they want in the short
term and they basically squeezed out the
old fogies who were viewed as dinosaurs
by it by these people you can see this
shift by the late 70s and it was in full
swing by the early eighties you know
throughout the industry
the commercial bankers somewhat
different paths to the same types of
cultural shifts in their case because of
huge write offs and their traditional
lines of business and the development of
of money market mutual funds and
together those the write offs and the
competing sources of funding started to
convince people that the old ways of buy
and hold banking were dying and you had
to start to move toward the converting
yourself to basically becoming a an
investment bank if you wanted to survive
and so the result was certainly by the
early 80s they made the decision to move
out of dead-end commercial banking and
adopt the ways of the of the brokerage
houses and not the old ways of the
brokerage houses but the new high-risk
high-return rapacity of a lot of the new
emissive banking firms so they moved in
securities so the the bankers of
commercial bankers moved in securities
and derivatives bankers trust being the
first but the others following and again
away from a buy and hold concern for
making the right investment decisions
and sticking with them to originate to
distribute model where you basically
don't basically don't give a [ __ ] about
what the thing will last or the security
will actually pay off in the long run
the question is whether you've gotten
your commission the short run they start
making markets and financial risk they
promoters traders and salesmen or line
overall line loan officers who were like
the old fogies and in the brokerage
industry they went away from a modest
base salary and minor bonus and to a
sky's the limit commission based comp so
smarter and more aggressive people
started to force out the old fogies just
like the brokerage houses just about you
know five years later
but so you have these trends in the
finance business but well then you say
have another trend driving in and turn
down the same direction on the on the
top corporate management's because if
with the first time you want finance
hostile takeover which was Revlon having
been a success I've been a success all
of a sudden everyone looked around as a
holy cow you know I meant risk to
anybody's at risk
well it's eat or be eaten so and I'm not
gonna be the victim I'm gonna be the
predator so so the ideas satisficing
balancing stakeholders interests will
start being viewed as for losers you're
a winner or a loser you don't balance
[ __ ] so you know all these things have
multiple ripples are multiple
consequences some of which are highly
negative some of which are undeniably
positive it probably was the same types
of event in higher bong of finance
hostile takeovers which created this
noxious soup of spiritual attitudes
which also created a huge bull market
the likes of which we had never seen
1982 the u.s. started on his 18 year
bull run with the ESPE major planetary
stomachs earnings multiples expanding
from eight times in 1982 to 33 times in
1999 and with with another metric which
is health stocks trade versus the
takeover value basically increasing from
say about 35 to 40 percent to 70 to 80
percent over that period of time just a
fantastic expansion of earnings and
multiples which the likes of which I
don't think I don't think there was any
other equivalent period in American
history in terms of how this shift of
the psychology there was a meteor in the
sky was called Gibson greetings in
nineteen
- in over 18 months it produced he's 66
to 1 equity return 18 months 66 to 1 and
everyone and management's around the
country say holy cow
66 for one well the answer is I can get
mine I'm at risk the downside I'm at
nights I'm at risk from some sort of
higher bond financed takeover the upside
is I can do an LBO of my own company and
be able to get just the gifts and
greeting type of return easy money
beyond any of my wildest dreams and I've
got control and I'm gonna use it as if
this wasn't enough to destabilize the
old ways of doing things
mutual funds were also replacing old
line institutions so the old line
institutions like say Morgan Guaranty
Trust Department would be stable funding
sources very long-term approach
relationship oriented by an old
conservative patient wonderful
stockholders if you're growing five to
six percent a year and don't let any
trouble
mutual funds were highly unstable
funding sources and they would have had
a much different focus very short term
high turnover meaning they bought sold a
lot of stocks they didn't have a lot of
patience they're much more capital gains
oriented not yield oriented they relied
on sell-side research they didn't know
much about the companies they were
investing in so your quarterly earnings
numbers were key they had a very short
attention span and very short tempers if
you if you missed your earnings
estimates by a penny they would dump all
over you screaming you and then sell
your stock without limit on the other
hand if you beat up by penny and they
were delightful people to be around so
it was but it was so different from the
old old institution so the I call it the
mutual fund ization the effects of this
mutual fund ization on public company
managed
as if the high-yield bond effect was not
enough was to make for much more
pressure for short-term returns
regardless of long-term possible risks
much more emphasis on hitting your
quarterly EPS targets because most of
the mutual fund investors had no idea
what they're investing and they really
didn't I know you know it's that sounds
like a ridiculous claim if I had a lot
more time I would expand on that it
really is true which is why index funds
have ended up quite justifiably taking
things over because the other people
really we're not creating value for what
they were charging so the effect of LBOs
management's and especially boards
became in your to high debt levels and
top execs started to expect huge upside
regardless of whether there was an LBO
hostile takeovers had the effect of
making time managers much more sensitive
their personal exposure and much less
concerned about balancing anything you
know forget about balancing that's for
losers
just how much can that money can I make
in the short term because I might be
taken over next year so what happens
when you do that well you know the time
management starts to see major increases
in the company business risk awesome
posture because remember we're looking
for maximizing return not worrying about
long-term risks that risk posture
includes not only sort of substantive
economic risk taking but also accounting
risk so I'm happy to take more
accounting risk I'm happy to play more
games with reserves I'm happy to ignore
problems because in the short term I'm
you know my earnings are going to look
great and then I'm going to make it
shitload of money and then someone else
can worry about the long term but when
you so you have a top managers at the
center and they have ripple effects on
all the concentric circles of
gatekeepers so the so the first to feel
real pressure were the accountants worse
or
had to show more profits with less
disclosure than old principles and
procedures would have allowed without
even admitting you're changing your
policies because you had to show results
either to make money for the for the CEO
or at least to keep Raiders away but you
can't just leave it at the accountants
because you have to have parallel
disclosure between what your footnotes
say and what you say in the text of of
your 10k for example you need to have
parallel disclosure where there's no
there's no chain there's no way people
get inside by exploiting differences
between the two disclosures called only
you have to have your lawyers being able
to get on board and they have to bless
more aggressive less fair disclosure and
they took a lawyers took a little bit
longer but ultimately they started
following along with the accountants in
blessing disclosure that would have been
unthinkable you know 10 years before the
board of directors you can't threaten
unlike accountants and lawyers you you
start threatening the Board of Directors
you get into a real problem so you can't
threaten them but you strike to bring
them along to increase you know make
sure that gradually they get replaced by
people who are more friendly to your new
way of business
you wear them down where they finally
get used to your increasing overall
corporate risk posture without without
ever admitting of course that your
accountants and lawyers are taking a
shitload more risk the other the crucial
committee and every board is the
compensation committee absolutely key
that's the one where you want to get
your friends on because that's they're
the ones who determine your compensation
then the rest the board rubber-stamp
said so they people started working very
hard on the compensation committees but
given because that became where the name
of the game was so what happened so
instead of bonuses you started having
options and then and then the the
efficient market hypothesis which became
dominant
time of course stocks always perfectly
reflect the economic fundamentals and so
therefore options must be a way to go
because you can always rely on the stock
price being perfect reflection of what's
going to happen the options were alleged
to create parallel management
shareholder incentives no downside for
shareholders were all in the same boat
although it's not the case and as a
result in the 90s huge option packages
packages became the norm so instead of a
zero percent of compensation as it was
in the 50s it became upwards about half
by the 90s and so people started driving
each and every decision over the short
term effects on your stock price and
therefore is you had a hugely leveraged
position through the options you know
you were expecting that you would you
know make your 20 40 60 100 million
dollars in a couple of years if you
could be able to transform the company
into a high-risk high-return machine so
it was there were other there are other
aspects which were perverse about the
options in terms of accounting we won't
go into that but it was it's just the
ideal thing for for huge huge packages
for for Tom management's so what so what
happened and in terms of how the CEO
would deal with its various gatekeepers
well less loyalty to professional
gatekeepers if you can't do what I want
or get someone who will and they really
meant it and the gatekeepers you know at
least accountants and lawyers started
you know saloons everybody realized it
they you all the the business strategies
the capital structures and disclosure
policies all became high risk
Nestle oh that's like a trifecta
trifecta
you know everything gets levered up and
in a way that is much higher risk even
though it's not really disclosed in a
fair way that it's much higher risk with
the CEO making huge corporate dollars of
the corporate bets payoff but not not
any comments or downside because of the
nature of options and the other effect
is in conjunction with what the mutual
fund ization was the emphasis on a droid
earnings management so you wanted so you
wanted to have this perfect
ideally 12 to 15 percent compound growth
in your annual earnings and be able to
beat your quarterly earnings estimate by
one penny every quarter I think in the
case of GE I think they beat their
earnings estimates by one penny for
something like 79 out of 80 quarters and
they were they the dream machine for a
lot of a lot of investors well what
happened to the professionals like the
lawyers and accountants well there was
an increasing focus i'm not ethical
issues but risk assessment so we enter
an amoral world of risk in return they
became much more money oriented because
they saw less talent and they really
were less talented investment bankers
pay soaring beyond theirs and they felt
they had to keep up for the same group
so they had to make a lot more money so
they chose not a so they chose not to
keep the same fees but maintain their
conservatism instead they dramatically
escalated their fees and took a lot more
risk the general level of ethics
declined because again it's almost like
a luxury item
so imagine someone who's wants to
maintain face in an upper-middle class
environment
and he really any any an eID sort of has
these comparison groups and he has a
notion of status which is perfectly you
know purely materialistic and purely
conformity oriented well you start
slipping in versus some of your
comparison groups well that's
unthinkable you know what's her life is
that so
what's getting in the way well if ethics
gets in the way you know you emphasize
risk in return and that's and as
shocking as it sounds now that's exactly
what happened so they so basically they
didn't lower their fees to compete they
increased the risk and when gatekeeper
firms take on extra risk what that
really means is they start to provide
ratification and support for
increasingly questionable client
disclosures that's taking reputational
and legal risk if you don't watch it and
both auditors and lawyers started
engaging in what I feel were disclosure
facades yes maybe I'll still try this is
too busy but basically was trying to
show is there's a self-perpetuating
cultural loop where you have an initial
shock which changes the CEOs assessment
of how he looks at the situation ethics
for service from return pressure
subordinates for a better company
results presto change-o you have more
profits board said how fantastic will
reward the CEO with a large stock option
package intensify pressure not only on
the support at this time on the
professional gatekeepers to be able to
play along the gatekeepers culture of
shifts and then gatekeeper sign-off on
where to school and a deceptive
disclosures bigger profits and it keeps
going like that and that happened more
than a lot of people realize so the
auditors developed a major consulting
practices which was viewed as a low risk
high return business provided which
flowed from your existing auto business
which was viewed as a dead end business
so the main thing you wanted to do is is
not rock the boat with your client in
the audit business so you could get the
consulting business
the one group that didn't change really
changed a little bit not a lot was that
was the Board of Directors and it's all
these things huge revolutionary changes
they didn't change they were still
docile and trusting maintaining their
traditional deference very concerned
about etiquette not rocking the boat not
trying to make a fellow director look
stupid not trying to ask too many
pointed questions because that wouldn't
be good and so they basically ignored
the changes that were going on they
denied the changes in their own firms
they denied the increasing risk posture
and they basically sort of pretty much
stuck their head in the sand unless they
were forced to come to confront the
obvious which they did only as a last
resort
unfortunately the SEC and the Fed and a
similar head-in-the-sand a point of view
and that is because of the efficient
market hypothesis which started to
permeate and the DC and the 80s about
the markets asserted rationality
efficiency self-correcting capabilities
almost perfection and then market
insights are so complete you don't have
to worry about them about the details of
accounting and the management's and
gatekeepers can be trusted to do the
right thing because their long-term
profit maximizers and of course you if
everyone knows everything you know you
have to protect your valuable reputation
so they assume absolute perfect perfect
geniuses with access to every bit of
information imaginable and that's how
they looked at the public markets won
that case you don't really would be a
regulator do you well they they came
close to that they allowed they loved
that maybe occasionally private sector
players do the wrong thing but that's
exceptional and you don't need to work
be worried about a government regulation
lower societal efficiency and most
securities and banking statutes are
unnecessary and no if you had if you had
all these changes but you
traditional sec and feds may be
overzealous at times regulation we
probably wouldn't have had the
explosions we ended up having of major
frauds in the early part of this century
but it was a it was a perfect storm so
we don't have to go through the details
of the fact it was mostly under Reagan
that when this really started when the
SEC really started to abandon this rigor
but it was continued under Clinton as
well so whether it's Democrats or
Republicans basically they hands from
the SEC and it was felt to be
unnecessary the Fed had the same type of
trajectory mostly after Greenspan became
chairman in terms of undermining the
Roosevelt administration legislation
glass-steagall which had restrained the
banks from being able to fully enter the
wild world of the brokerage houses and
they in the 90s under under Clinton they
they they helped various forces in
Congress and in the Clinton
administration defeat the CFTC's attempt
to regulate swaps which I believe was
was instrumental in terms of the
financial crisis again a view is that
any regulation stifles all these
geniuses who are only trying to create
value for the rest of us so it's the
basically you know the good news is that
the tradition is which hamstrung some of
these industries and the finance were
thrown out the bad news is that one of
the traditions that was thrown out was
ethics
we're viewed as sort of relegated to a
den history public companies as a whole
also started to relegate ethics to the
dead history so the old CEO question
which admittedly was not maximizing of
economic efficiency I don't have portray
this is it a dream world they were
hidden in its own problems but how can
the company achieve reasonable
profitability while honoring its
obligations to its various
constituencies maintaining its
well-deserved reputation no very starchy
low-growth you know a sort of approach
the new question is how can i exploit
the situation to help achieve my net
worth goals with acceptable personal
legal risk very different questions you
know and that's and that that was the
shift and there are there are
consequences of both so it's it's and
we're living with them even if we don't
seem to see that day to day so we have a
concern for the other party and in a
business transaction going down concern
for the long-term going down the trust
and trustworthiness among the private
players except for boards going down and
regulators descending into their
dogmatic slumbers so I mean it's just
again the makings of a perfect storm
which no one no one expected of course
because of the efficient market
hypothesis so the perfect expression of
this but there were others was in line
and each party in the Enron and the
unlock fraud had a part to play so a a
which was one that one of the major
accounting firm is very firm with 100
year old history provided crucial
consulting services they in effect they
provided consulting services
for how to conduct frauds to Enron as
well as onto fees they received over
fifty million dollars a year in annual
fees from from Enron and the and they
ended up being convicted of obstruction
of justice and dying as a going concern
in 2002 but having made hundreds of
millions of dollars helping Enron be
able to engage in it's very
sophisticated fraud it was really an
impressive an impressive regime of of
lies lawyers also had to be involved
with AAA because you have to get into
parallel these these various disclosure
parts of your disclosure package they
gave crucial opinions blessing numerous
phony deals which opinions were were
acquired for AAA to be able to provide
their expertise ations and they provided
informal endorsements of the various
crooked deals that fast outdid which
rolled a board which did not want to
think very carefully lull them to sleep
the only difference between them in AAA
is that a was destroyed as a firm and I
think one firm I think being a bit sin
Howkins may have a twenty five million
dollar fine which was roughly six months
of Billings for one year so
unfortunately unlike the accountants
were destroyed by the by the fraud in
this case the lawyers and ended up doing
really well and yet the fraud could not
have occurred without their active
involvement in the overall process which
they put an operative this way knew or
should have known how their various form
over substance opinions we're gonna be
used but it wasn't just that look at the
banks
Thanks paid its top dozen banks 300
million dollars in fees in the last five
years of its existence the all of 16 and
sell-side analysts actually Street
analysts have eyes are better'n over
strong buys and then line as of a couple
of weeks before it went broke the the
banks were touting the the Enron public
securities were also marketing the
private equity interests in the
fraudulent conflict-ridden
off-balance sheet arrangements that
ultimately killed the company ultimately
the major banks paid about six and a
half billion dollars to some of the
claims they aided and abetted and a lot
of long extended and elaborate fraud so
these were the banks that Greenspan
would have said would never engage in in
any file dealing because of their
concerns over long-term reputation these
are the banks that that you know the Fed
and the SEC no longer felt they really
had to regulate because of course
they're always going to do the right
thing and occasionally by accident bad
decisions be made but never in a
systemic basis I believe that what Emlyn
shows is how deep the rock was into the
major banks which of course becomes
important because several years later
admittedly about five years later the
banks themselves nearly go bankrupt
because of the same approaches that
Enron used off-balance sheet vehicles
lousy disclosure highly risky practices
that are are never explained to
stockholders the board and Enron never
bothered to discuss in for this way
there was no evidence of a serious
discussion of the issues raised by the
these special dealings of the CFO
who chose to create lots of little alter
egos to Enron to then trade with with
Enron and there's no one in the bourse
that she does that make sense I mean she
would be showing earnings for something
that is merely a creek a creation of our
own control by us is that well those
rail earnings or maybe is that sort of
hocus-pocus no discussion and they had
even and even the people on the Finance
Committee later maintained they had no
understanding of the off-balance sheet
deals that Enron was doing you're on the
Finance Committee you have no idea what
your own company is doing so maybe you
should actually act like a real
fiduciary in that merely a sort of
phony-baloney simulacrum of a fiduciary
so effectively the outsource their
entire accounting system to may a and
didn't bother to look for whether a a
was actually engaging in a true vetting
the SEC also didn't bother to review the
filings of Enron even though there were
huge related party transaction footnotes
which are usually give away something's
weird going on there are many special
SEC permissions given where they gave
Enron special exemption from the
securities laws to be able to show
profits for certain types of
transactions but once they gave the
exemption did they ever look back and
see how yeah I see how Enron was
actually applying exemption whether it
was still within the same general orbit
or same with whether they were actually
using good-faith judgment no what you
don't have to because again people
always do the right thing so you don't
have to worry about that
so in the case of top management what
was the effect of all this on them and
and in their case they stopped looking
at the job of a company to create in
real economic terms and cash terms
increases in value for society and the
stockholders so all corporate life that
came from them was a series of games
whether it was accounting games or
sexual games there was a lot of sexual
harassment going on you know they it was
all a game and they never had any
obligations anyone they were worthy of
note they became incredibly endured too
risky capital structures as the company
seemed to proc prosper and by the way
when you there's a normally of a lot of
volatility in the way earnings really
occur in most companies and when you see
the volatility you get an intuitive
sense of how much risk there is which
tends to restrict how much debt you
might take on but an Enron escapes what
they would do is play games with the
accounting so that if they had a loss on
an asset they never recognized it if
they needed some extra earnings they
just marked an asset up and so what you
end up doing is having this this sort of
strange quiet and perfection of results
or you where eventually what happens is
that you your lies to outsiders become
your own reality and trying to lie to
others you end up lying to yourself
because you you literally forget your
own how deeply embedded your own lies
are in your life so they started to
believe their own financials having
known their result concocted when you
look again the brezza
actually in a way this is when I look in
what happened in the in the change of
cultures and in London which I believe
is a forerunner of the financial crisis
the really important thing ends up being
probably this slide because it's the
personal impact on people and the person
that penny and the incredibly secure ik
sort of attitudes that people develop as
they slowly slip into what I consider to
be I don't know how to put it really an
evil way of life I don't know whether he
was like this before but during the
course of his of his of his reign at
Enron the person who had been the CEO
and became a CEO for a while Jeff
Skilling made it very clear you rejected
all traditional boundaries unacceptable
business practice strategic financial
ethical that really ethics is merely the
attempt of the weak man and to bind the
strong man and that ethical constraints
are no more worthy of note than the
finance covenants in a loan agreement
that in the world that skilling in and I
believe and in Iran traders and I'd say
a lot of finance people in our country
this is why I'm still worried because no
one ever went to jail of knows you had
that you have basically the rejection of
all the traditional boundaries
unacceptable business practice and
intention a virtue doing exploiting all
information that these symmetries as a
virtuous shows how sharp you are and and
the rationale or rationalization becomes
if those people are stupid enough to
believe you they deserve what they get
and that includes the problem is that
includes not only the people out there
customers not only includes your
competitors that attitude ends up being
an attitude where you start to view
everyone around you that way and you
start to look at your family is well
what do they want it's a trade I'm
engaging in a trade with my wife and my
daughter whoever it is to trade am I
gonna lose the trade or win the trade
and everything becomes a zero-sum game
everything becomes for a predator and
prey loser and winner and you're gonna
win the trade or lose the trade now your
your daughter may just want to go out
for a walk well what is she really was
she she wasn't she probably wants the
manipulated me it's that sounds like a
caricature and it is a lot of people but
it's not when you get into that mindset
and that's the mindset and when I got
into and I would submit that's what made
the financial crisis inevitable is that
that mindset permeated finance and Enron
basically was it was just an
unregistered hedge fund so you know the
final you know more positively but its
but still just as deadly and it's I
think it's in its typical of the
efficient market hypothesis the
assumption is that individuals
spontaneously coalesce into productive
economic aggregates there's no need for
centralized control or even social norms
people at Enron believe that I think in
a lot of ways people in the big banks
believe that and the regulators believe
that which is what why all of this was
completely inevitable and I think I
don't I have anything else it's
basically the same story so on let's see
if it'll end up being so I'll just
finish here and that is it below what
was what was unimportant to all these
co-conspirators include the Board of
Directors they weren't really a
conspirator what was of low importance
was legitimate interest of other part
in the business concern for the long
term go to the business and the possible
moral claims embedded in the substance
of securities laws and accounting
principles that that is so important and
that is what I guarantee you has been
lost throughout moderate and corporate
America accounting it's merely became
disclosure is a game are you gonna win
or you're gonna lose and of course the
high importance is exploiting
asymmetries in every business
relationship and defeating lesser
individuals who attempt to bind you with
rules morals and laws and I just leave
it there because it goes on but it's
it's the same as basically it's
basically the same type of being
repeated over and over where more and
more people are sort of trapped by this
thinking and by the way these people
make huge amounts of money and as far as
I could tell from personal dealings with
them were wildly unhappy individuals
which i think is the most important part
of this actually the only reason I do
this because it's you see the waste of a
human life yeah you make out a couple
hundred million dollars yes and
Americans all think that the more money
equals more happiness which i think is
[ __ ] but anyway but it's it's the
dreadful effects on most of these people
and I'm not talking about high tech
maybe high tech operates by separate
rules
I'm not making any comments about that I
only know the traditional traditional
part of the economy and the finance
business with the loss when you finally
decide you don't like anybody else
and I mean anybody you don't like
anybody else you don't want to be with
anybody else all you have with are
things and I personally believe we're
made for relationships with other beings
they're people whether there's Divine
Being as you can conceive of it hell
even dogs but beings and if finally you
have a traitor mentality
where it's all a Hobbesian battle for
survival and you're gonna win the other
guy's going to lose you end up with no
relationships and I don't care how rich
you are you're your toast in the end you
can be living in a 50,000 square foot
mansion and have no human relationships
and there's something there's a legacy
part of your spirit that says
something's not right here I'm not happy
but maybe it'll be a little bit better
if I make another million bucks today
screwing somebody and again this sounds
like a caricature
I wish it were caricature it really
isn't and that's why I believe we had
the thing you know maybe things like
Enron with the finance crisis and what
I'm still worried today about what will
happen ten years from now when I believe
the next period of quiescence will lead
to just this sort of deregulation with
another explosion anyway
happy days are here that's good it's
self-evident self-explanatory I like
that thank you very much
and do you have any questions for mr.
Alexander that's okay do you think it's
possible to be ethical and still be
successful in the finance industry yeah
I mean this you know it's it would go on
to launders to to be able to not only
convince people of the problem but also
to go through my last job where
basically we did everything the right
way
ended up being a competitive juggernaut
as it was in the what's called the
upstream oil gas how are you searching
for natural gas the Gulf of Mexico doing
things the right way
developing a corporate culture which was
very efficient more efficient than
others which reserved in effect are all
our our brain power for actually solving
societal problems effectively and
efficiently not lying about how well
we've done and so we it was it took
about ten years and by the standards of
high tech it says no you know an abysmal
failure but but we had any ten for one
return unleveraged on the equity
starting this company running it the
right way and then selling it to a large
of all company everyone everyone that
started with the company within the
first year became a millionaire we've
broadly distributed the equity we all
cooperated we made clear to the
employees that we are always going to
tell the truth down
ciders so the employees saw that we not
only talk the talk but walk the walk and
a lot of companies you know in line for
example have a fabulous vision statement
it was [ __ ] and within so what the
employee said I see what you're doing
you're just lying to your outside ok I
know how the game is played zone why
you're lying a lot so we knew we had to
establish a completely truth oriented
organization to be able to get people to
live that way and to cooperate and
that's what we did and so I'm convinced
you can make excellent money not by the
standards of the top point one percent
but by the standards certainly a bit 99
percent of the people who have ever
lived you can make fantastic money not
going around strong people and actually
doing the right thing entering into
transactions where you're where you and
the counterparty end up better and you
know that's you can't tell from the
outside by the way which companies and
they're still you know they're still
company is even in finance that try to
do the right thing consistently what
everyone talks a great game and you
can't know who's really walking the walk
as well as talking to talk until you get
in there so my advice to you all anybody
if you go into finance your first job
should be just getting the lay of the
land figuring out who really is trying
to do the right thing and is efficient
and smart gravitate to those companies
and don't feel inculcated if you're
involved on teams that end up screwing
someone because you're not you're not
driving the bus you're just finding out
who really does try to do the right
thing and then when that happens don't
choose your job for the last 10,000
dollars you know that extra $10,000 if
you're in a in a company that is a
miserable excuse
for human beings you will you'll end up
less happy than if you were in the right
company doing the right thing for
slightly less money and a lot of people
though go for that last ten thousand
dollars and it isn't it's not it's not
worth it it really isn't you know now
there are I'll accept certain people us
I think 3 to 5 percent of the population
psychopaths for those people this is the
right path
their happiness when they're you know
but I'm but 95 percent of us really are
not happy when we're screwing at other
people and you should realize there's a
core in yourself that you'll never be
able to get really get rid of and if
that core is basically right and moral
if you try to get rid of it
you'll what you'll do is you'll end up
if you're smart person end up being able
to do a good job in many ways make lots
of money but you'll never be able to get
rid of that inner voice it'll never be
right again I can excepting out the
Psychopaths
[Music]
would it have been possible for and Ron
to work like reverse their business
practices to be more ethical again or
not again
we're like just to be more ethical or
what were they in too deep they if they
had actually if they had actually chosen
in the mid-90s to advertise to the
markets that they were going to be
growing earnings per share at eleven to
twelve percent a year as opposed to the
15 percent minimum they might have had a
chance but they were if you think about
the compounding of it of a twelve
percent compound an increased line
versus a a sixteen percent you know it
starts out small gets bigger and bigger
the spread between those two lines was
the measure of their mendacity required
mendacity so in the mid 90s they had a
chance by the time it came to the you
know 2001 it was it was far away too
late to do anything because there were
rot and had really or the infection or
the cancer had metastasized throughout
the whole body
it started as I think it started though
with the decision in the mid 90s to
advertise a ridiculously high earnings
per share trajectory for an old economy
company and and and they never had a
chance after that and they never try
well you know I'm glad I don't have to
figure out the incentive compensation
systems for JPMorgan or something like
that
in the firms that actually I where I was
high enough in the hierarchy where I saw
what they're trying to do we're much
smaller like several hundred people at
most a lot of it is who gets promoted
you know if you have someone who well
for example for example I won't I will
say that the person is but I left this
firm pretty quickly but remember of my
first day and one of my firm's a young
partner was holding forth in an office
traveling about how he gotten an
assistant treasurer fire and assistant
treasurer's our pesky bunch but he
probably about how he gotten him fired
because he challenged this guy in one of
his fees and then people that's what was
the thing it's about double what it
should have been and that's when the
young partner exploded in tales of
laughter and saying the assistant
treasurer was absolutely right it was
unconscionable that's why I had to get
him fired so a lot of the incentives can
be at least in organizations up to
several hundred people can be just
through familiarity of the boss with
what the subordinates doing through
bonuses you don't have to have no
questions asked commissions and who you
promote ends up being important so in
other words if other people see
Psychopaths being promoted they see what
type of a behavior is rewarded so a lot
of the incentives
end up being making sure that you're
aware of behavior which is mutually
profitable to your firm and also to the
to the customer you reward that even if
it's just with a pat on the back or an
annual bonus and you make sure that the
sort of psychopaths and I saw this one
firm are squeezed now not as it turned
out immensely rewarded to the highest
post in the whole firm so I know if
that's an answer but this I mean it's a
it can be done although I'm walking into
a JP Morgan might be a daunting task
okay thank you very much
[Music]